- Le mouvement #MeToo,
#MoiAussi, as s s s s s s s s sn
11 ans plus tôt.
Et c'est cette femme,
Tanara Burke, une travailleuse
sociale quququququququququququqr
les violences sexuelles commises
sur les petites filles noires.
Tout a commencé en Alabama,nt,
Tanara Burke est monitrice
de camp de jour pour
adolescentes, des jeunes filles
racisées et peu nante e e e e e,
13 ans, est décisive.
Un jour, le e e e fille, qui est
réputée pour son tempérament
difficile, demande à lui parler
victime de violences sexuelles
de la u u u u copain de sa mère.
Tarana Burke qui, à ce moment
est elle-même survivante deeeeee
au bout de cinq minutes,cacacacr
sa confidence.
Heaven quitta le camp de joaia.
En 20nanananara Burke lance
donc l'Association MeToo.
Une initiative née du regret
"moi aussi" à Heaven.
(slogan)eseseseseseseseseseseses
pour que le mouvement soit mis
sous les projecteurs,
dans la foulée des accusations
de harcèlement sexuelteteteteteu
Harvey Weinstein.
Cette enquête du "New York
qui se délient une à la fois,tte
Alyssa Milano dans laquelle
elle invite toutes les femmememt
ou d'agression sexuelle
à y répondre en utilisant
le mot-clic #MeToo.
C'est le début d'un phénomène
social planétaire. Même si,
dans une seconde publication,
l'ac
de MeToo bien avant elle,
c'est la fracture de 2017
qui marque les esprits.hahahahat
une survivante de violences
sexuelles. c c c c c c c c c c e
au doctorat en service social
- Quand il était question
de jeunes filles de milieux
défavorisés, bien, ça n'mememem.
Donc, il y a des questionnements
à avoir là-dedans.
- Des filles issues
d'une communauonononononononono.
- Ça peut être perçu comme
une trahison par des membres
de la communauté de dénoncer
un hompar exemple.
- Pour faire tomber ces
barrières, cette intervenante
croit qu'il faut miser sur
culturellement adaptés.
MARLIHAN LOPEZ, collaboratrice,
Institut Simone de Beauvoir
- En tant que survivante,
expériences ou les expériences
de femmes autour de moi
effacées, pas incluses dans
la conversation autour des
- Malgré les défis,
les deux femmes contntntntnt
de se battre pour que
toutes les voix comptent.
- Ça inclut aussi les jeunes
qui sont victimes dencncncnces
sexuelles, les personnes
des communautés LGBT.
ces personnes-là, on va vraiment
avoir un mouveuiuiuiui va
pouvoir, en fait, libérer
tout le monde, et non seulement
- Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radidadadada, Montréal.